[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BACOW: Good evening.
My name is Larry Bacow, and as
Chancellor of the Institute,
it's my pleasure
to welcome you all
to the inaugural lecture in
the Ford Nobel Laureate Lecture
Series.
This series will bring
Nobel laureates to MIT
from throughout the
world to discuss
important work in their fields.
All of the fields in which
Nobel Prizes are awarded
will be represented
in this series.
Ford Nobel lectures
will be scheduled
throughout the fall
and the spring terms
over the next five years.
We're very grateful
to Ford Motor Company
for sponsoring this series.
It's part of an
extensive partnership
between Ford and
MIT which focuses
on research and education.
MIT faculty and students
are working collaboratively
with Ford in a variety of
fields that encompass virtually
all five of MIT schools.
We're collaborating on projects
as diverse as the environment,
e-commerce, combustion
engineering,
virtual engineering,
and virtual education.
This partnership is helping to
define new models of university
industry collaboration and
we're very proud of it.
It had been my plan at
this point in the evening
to introduce Dr. Martin
Zimmerman, the vice
president for government
affairs at Ford who was going
to introduce our speakers.
Unfortunately, Marty's
plane has been delayed.
And he'll be joining us
later on in the program.
So it becomes my pleasure to
introduce our three speakers.
I've invited Marty
when he gets here
to come up and actually
close the program
and thank our panelists.
Since I won't have
an opportunity
to properly introduce
him at the time,
just let me tell you a
little bit about Marty.
He's an alumnus of our
economics department
where he received his
PhD, former faculty member
and our Sloan School,
after which he went on
to become a faculty member at
the Graduate School of Business
at the University of Michigan.
He's been a wonderful
friend of the Institute
and has played a major role in
helping to create the Ford MIT
partnership.
And we're very
grateful for his help
and in sponsoring
this event today.
Our three speakers tonight
really need no introduction.
Now Marty told me when I
spoke to him earlier today
that he once said that when
he was about to introduce
one of his bosses.
And the response was, well,
you know, that's true,
but I prefer if you go
ahead and did it anyway.
So let me just say a few words
about Paul Samuelson, Franco
Modigliani, and Bob Solow.
If I really tried to
describe all of their honors
and awards and honorary
degrees, we really
wouldn't have time for
the interesting work
of this evening, which
is their remarks.
So I will be brief.
Professor Samuelson received
the Nobel Memorial Prize
in economic science in 1970
for the scientific work
through which he
has developed static
and dynamic economic theory
and actively contributed
to raising the level of
analyses in economic science.
That's a direct quotation
from the Nobel citation.
As Assar Lindbeck said in
the presentation speech,
Professor Samuelson
has, in fact, simply
rewritten considerable
parts of economic theory.
He has also shown
the fundamental unity
of both the problems and
analytical techniques
in economics.
Any introduction of
Professor Samuelson
would not be complete
without noting
that he is the author
of what I believe
is the most popular textbook
in the history of not just
economics but all of
American higher education.
Professor Modigliani received
the Nobel Memorial Prize
in economic science
in 1985 for quote,
"his pioneering
analyses of savings
and of financial markets."
The achievements for
which he was recognized
included the life-cycle
hypothesis of household savings
and for the formulation of
the Modigliani-Miller theorems
of the valuation of firms
and of capital costs.
Franco has been a consultant
and involved with governments
throughout the world.
And we have all been very
grateful for his contributions
to our economics department as
with Paul for many, many years.
Professor Solow received
the Nobel Memorial Prize
in economic science in
1987 for his contributions
to the theory of
economic growth.
The Nobel Committee cited
the enormous influence
of the Solow growth
model and his work
on empirical growth analysis.
And, indeed, as we
come to understand
the role of technological change
and productivity and the role
that it is playing in
our economy today, again,
we turn to the
work of Bob Solow.
Now, the Nobel Prize
recognizes the contributions
of these three men to the
field of economic science.
It really is awarded
for their research.
But in point of fact,
beyond their research,
each of these men have
made absolutely enormous
contributions to the education
of generations of economists,
not just at MIT, but
throughout the world.
Indeed, I don't think
I'm overstating it
when I say that they
are at least as loved
and as is well-regarded
for the wonderful work
they have done as members
of our economics faculty
as they are for
their contributions
to economic science.
So tonight, they are going to
take the long view, both back
and forward, taking a look at
our economy the last 50 years--
and what I'm sure
everybody's anxious to hear--
their prognostication of the
economy for the next 50 years.
Please join me
again in welcoming
three giants of our field, Paul
Samuelson, Franco Modigliani,
and Bob Solow.
[APPLAUSE]
SAMUELSON: The last time I saw
this hall full to overflowing
was when I had the duty
to debate Milton Friedman.
It was a question of one
lion and one Christian.
And I will not tell you
which part was mine.
Tonight, I expect, will
be a piece of cake.
All I have to do is
to discuss with you
the major economic problems
in the upcoming decade.
When I first wrote my
best selling economics
textbook at World War
II's end, I correctly
identified what would be
the major economic problem
of the upcoming
quarter of a century.
Simply put, it was avoiding
the depression, unemployment
that blighted the 1930s.
That was then.
Now is 2000.
My choice now, looking ahead,
not to a quarter of a century
but just for a decade, is
what is the major problem?
And I believe it to
be how to work out
the Aristotelian
golden mean that
weighs the delicate compromise
between what we render
to the market price
mechanism and what
we render to democratic
government interferences
by the democratic welfare state.
And my remarks build
up to that problem.
Back at the end of World War
II, all the standard textbooks
were still stuck in the 1920s
orthodoxy of pure capitalism.
I knew that system.
I grew up under that system.
I sold Norman Rockwell
Saturday Evening Posts.
There were no unions.
Up to the time of my infancy,
childhood, and adolescence,
that was the system.
But after the Herbert
Hoover slump--
that is the only partisan remark
I will make in the evening--
MIT students and college
beginners everywhere
needed to learn the
Keynesian macroeconomics that
ushered in a generation of
unprecedented global growth
in the third quarter
of the 20th century.
For better or worse,
Franklin Roosevelt's New Deal
moved us into a mixed economy--
not pure capitalism, certainly
not bureaucratic command
communism of the
Stalin and Mao type.
Here at home and
similarly abroad almost
everywhere, the quasi
welfare state evolved.
Now what does that
mean concretely?
It means most of the
business of the society,
the economic business is left to
the allocation of market price
mechanism--
profit, loss, selfishness,
checks and balances.
First this was, so to speak,
a Monday to Friday affair.
But then on Sunday and,
increasingly, even on Saturday,
democratic governmental
legislatures and agencies
did lean against the wind of the
glaring inequalities generated
by the competitive price
private property mechanism.
Well, how did they
lean against the wind?
It wasn't old fashioned
socialism, government ownership
of the means of production.
It was done, as far as the
redistribution of income,
to attenuate the worst
inequalities, which will always
be generated by a laissez-faire
private profit system.
That has to be done
by the fiscal system.
Progressive taxation takes
more from the rich than
from the poor.
Redistributive
transfer expenditures,
unemployment insurance,
social security, poverty,
and welfare programs,
bank deposit insurance,
give to the poor and
lower income classes
more than it takes
from them by taxes.
Well, I won't use time
to describe that process
because you've
all lived in that.
You were born into it.
You've grown up into it.
However, about in the third
quarter of the century,
towards the last
part of the century,
nature cannot stand relative
prosperity and stability
and complacency.
By the quarter of the
century just ended,
in much of the world there has
grown up a conservative trend
away from altruism.
That is a fact about
modern democracy,
a different fact from the
laissez-faire society--
I'm sorry from the
1929 drift away
from the laissez-faire society.
And you've seen it
all over the globe.
You've seen it in presidencies
of Eisenhower, Nixon, Reagan,
elder George Bush.
Even in Scandinavia
and continental Europe
social democracies
retreated under attack.
Now, let me give you my take
on the two reasons for this.
It's axiomatic that
always the affluent
will hope to use their
money power to resist
populist demands to
have the government help
the masses at their expense.
I'm speaking of my
suburban neighbors,
people you all know,
mostly, actually,
your own parents, yeah.
However, before Keynes
showed us how to mostly tame
depressions the lower
3/4 of the income classes
of the electorate suffered
enough to goad them
into opposing the
disproportionate powers
in democratic real politic
of private business
and of affluence.
Our system is one
nose, one vote.
But our system of
how the votes count
is that if you have lots
of dollars in your wallet,
your effective voting
power will be greater.
So in the age after Keynes,
discontent atrophied
and lobbyists learned
how to operate.
Also many, from even the lowest
part of the middle classes,
came to overvalue their
own lottery ticket
probability of being one of
the rich favored by politics.
If you're taking
notes, I hope you'll
rewrite those tongue-tied
last couple of sentences.
But there was a
second possible reason
for the retreat from
voter-imposed altruism.
We do-gooders are
like Oliver Twist.
We always ask for more.
We are like the boy who
said he could spell banana
except that he didn't
know when to stop.
Going all the way, as
Lenin, Stalin, and Mao did,
was motivated, said
it was motivated
by good, if
unrealistic intentions.
But I'm not speaking of
communism and the recent ending
of the Cold War.
I'm speaking of societies
like those in Scandinavia,
in Israel, all over the world.
Once modern democracies
began to spend and organize
more than 50% of society's
potential GDP two things
seem to begin to happen.
Now, I'm giving you my
slant, my reading of events.
High tax rates do begin
to put considerable sand
in the economic cogwheels.
The mathematical
economist discovers
that these deadweight losses
against the efficiency
and growth progress will
increase with the square
of the altruistic scale.
I'm talking MIT talk.
I do not deny that
any noble cause should
be pushed some distance into
the law of diminishing returns.
But remember, we have
only one human nature.
It's that which evolved
from the Darwinian struggle
for existence.
And it seems to have
left us, all of us,
with only a limited endowment
of this precious altruism.
So altruism, I
believe, does need
to be rationed
carefully precisely
because of its scarcity.
Well, that's not all
about big government.
I started out as a--
how shall I describe myself.
I was trained by Jesuits at
the University of Chicago.
The cathedral of choice at
my University of Chicago
was the cathedral of
free private enterprise,
not of the medieval
Catholic church.
But once I threw off
that brainwashing--
because I was like a sponge,
I was a very good student,
so I was a sponge--
I reached a balanced
value judgment position.
Now, has it changed?
My arteries have hardened.
Have I followed the
usual course of becoming
more conservative as I age?
Now, I'm the greatest
expert on me.
So I would just tell
you that I don't
detect in myself very much
of a great change in value
judgments.
However I haven't been
asleep all these years.
And it was a great event for me
when Joseph McCarthy undertook
a witch hunt in
the United States
which reached deep into
every governmental circle,
deep into every academic group.
And I suddenly realized
what one big employer means.
When innocent friends of mine
were blackballed and lost
their job, if we'd gone
all the way, if we really
were a one employing
company, there
would be no place to hide.
They went to work
for hardware stores.
One became a treasure
of Mars candy company.
There is a certain
protection for all
of the do-gooder liberal
things that I treasure
in not having one big company.
Moreover-- and this is an
economic finding that I cannot
document precisely--
but something seems
to happen when even
in a very civilized part of
the world like Scandinavia
that part of the GDP that
goes through government hands
becomes 50%, 60%, when tax rates
become 92% out of every dollar,
you don't teach much
night school or summer
school under those conditions.
It isn't just that sand in the
cogs that I spoke of earlier.
But there is
something that becomes
unresponsive to human
needs in the decision
making of the
lobbyist, politician,
world that leads me
to the conclusion
that whereas I used
to in my MIT class
speak of the mixed economy,
of the welfare state,
I now speak of the limited mixed
economy, the limited welfare
state.
And so that brings me up to the
topic that I started out with.
What is the best compromise,
what are the best limits so
that we get the advantages
of the regulatory powers
of democratic government,
of the stabilization powers
of a Federal Reserve
central bank,
of a fiscal policy, which leans
against the wind when there are
no jobs it's the right
thing to lower taxes,
it's the right thing
to run deficits,
but it is not the right thing
to do those same things when
we are in a overheated, very
high employment economy?
Now, there are no simple rules.
Young assistant professors
will spend their lifetime
in working out documented
progress on that problem.
And that, I think,
is the major problem.
And maybe some of
it will come out
in the discussion that follows.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SOLOW: When we drew
lots not so long ago,
the decision was that Paul
would speak first on this panel
and I second and
Franco Modigliani last.
So it's my turn now.
And I'm going to talk about
slightly different things
from what you've just
heard from Paul Samuelson.
The first thing you
should keep in mind--
remember what the title
for this symposium
was, the last 50 years
and the next 50 years--
you should keep in mind that
the years from 1950 to 2000
were, in most economic ways,
in this country extraordinarily
successful.
By the way, the period
from 1950 to 2000
fits my lifetime very well.
1950 was the year in which
I finished my PhD thesis
and began teaching at MIT.
So the next 50 years
will cover roughly
the corresponding period
in many of your lives.
The next 50 years are
the years between--
the graduate students
in the room--
between now and when you are
old and doddering like us.
The question that was
raised, that we want to raise
and I want to raise
and discuss here
is you should be thinking
about is whether the next,
whether you will
have it so good,
whether the next 50 years can
be as successful as the last.
I don't want to bore you with
measurements of how much better
or how well the country
did in the last 50 years.
But one simple statistic is
that real consumption spending
per person in the
population, what
the average expenditure on
consumer goods and services
corrected for inflation was,
in 2000, 3 and 1/2 times what
it was in 1950.
Measured that way,
the standard of living
multiplied itself by 3 and 1/2.
By the way, I was
a little shocked
to discover that in 1950, almost
15% of the American workforce
was engaged in agriculture.
That number is now
between 2% and 3%.
But multiplying what command
over consumption goods
the average person has
by a factor of 3 and 1/2
is a pretty dramatic
transformation.
There were, however, failures
in that 50 year period.
First of all, the improvement in
the average standard of living
was not smooth or uniform.
There were recessions in 1954,
in 1958, in 1960, in 1970,
in 1975, in 1980, in
1982, and in 1991.
And you know the standard
newspaper puzzle,
what is the next term
in that progression?
You're not going to
learn that tonight.
There were also episodes of
inflation during that period.
Output per hour work,
productivity of labor in the US
grew rapidly early in the
period and then slowed down
and then may have sped up
again in the last few years.
A more worrying aspect of
that last 50 year period
was that the amount
of inequality
in the distribution of economic
goods was getting worse.
Inequality diminished early
in that 50 year period.
And then from about the
mid 1970s, turned around
and we had a long spell
of widening inequality,
a bigger spread between the
top and the bottom earners
in the population.
It looks as if that worsening
inequality may have stopped
in the past two or three years.
It's really too soon to know.
The data are fragmentary.
And in any case, there has even,
in the past two or three years,
not been any reversal
of widening inequality.
It may be that
between 1950 and 2000,
the incomes, the
real incomes of those
in the bottom third of
the income distribution
may actually have decreased.
By the way, those are
not the same people.
The people who were in the
bottom third of the income
distribution in 1950
are not the same people
who were in the
bottom third in 2000.
But if you think of that
as a role in society,
being one of the 33% poorest
people in the society,
then the real income
associated with that role
has probably actually
diminished in the past,
in the past 50 years.
We know, for instance, that
the earnings premium associated
with higher education has
increased and is still
increasing.
That's very good
for you and for us.
As a matter of fact, the
US has been very successful
at higher education.
People come from elsewhere to
go to universities in the US.
We have not done very
well at educating
the less talented part of
the population and the poor.
People don't come
from far away to go
to urban elementary schools
or high schools in the US.
One of the bad things
about the past 50 years
is that we risk perpetuating a
sort of permanent underclass.
But if the period from 1950
to 2000 was a success--
and I think despite the
problems that I mentioned,
that success was based mainly
on technological innovation,
improvements in economic
policy, and good luck,
in what proportions
it's very hard to say.
And this is, in a way, what
Paul was telling you about.
Some of those, many of those
improvements in economic policy
are probably traceable to
better economic analysis,
to a better understanding of
the way a mixed system like ours
works.
How about the next 50 years?
How about the years
when you will be as old
as the three of us are now?
No one can predict what
economic life in the US
will be like in 2050.
That's not because
we're bad at predicting.
It hasn't been determined yet.
God hasn't decided how good
things will be in 2050.
So how could we possibly know?
But there are some
fairly clear tendencies
that we can talk about.
For example, it's not just us,
but the population of the US
is aging.
And that's happening elsewhere
in the modern industrial world
as well.
There will be, 50
years from now,
relatively more
old people like us
and relatively fewer
young people like you.
That comes about for
several reasons--
first of all, because of
increasing longevity, also
because of smaller
family size, there
are fewer children
born on the average
to each woman in
modern societies.
And the aging of
the population also
has to do with a single
historical event, the baby
boom, the fact that about
1950, in fact, family sizes
and the size of a
completed family in the US
and elsewhere and the
world began to rise
and created a bulge
in the population.
That bulge, like a pig
swallowed by a snake,
is sort of creeping through
the body politic and--
SAMUELSON: Stop there.
SOLOW: Yes, I do not
intend to describe
the end of that process.
But before, before 2050, the
baby boom will have retired.
And this very important
fact, that the population
is getting relatively
older, is unlikely to be
reversed any time soon.
Immigration is an offset to
the aging of the population.
Immigrants tend to be
younger and more fertile,
have more children than
resident Americans.
But immigration is
unlikely to occur
in anything like large enough
numbers to reverse the process.
Why is the aging of the
population important?
It's important because
the working age population
shrinks as a proportion
of the total population.
If we want to look at the
standard of living at income
per person in the population,
we can describe that
as the product of two numbers--
income per worker
and the number,
the ratio of workers
to population.
And if the second
of those factors
gets smaller, as it undoubtedly
will, the standard of living
will tend to suffer unless
something else happens.
The average standard of
living will fall unless--
compared with what would have
been without this aging process
unless something
happens to change it.
We will simply have
fewer producers
relative to the
number of consumers.
There will be non-economic
consequences of the aging
of the population as well.
Nursing homes are going to
be more popular than nursery
schools relatively speaking.
And voters, voting will change.
Old voters are different
from young voters.
By the way, you
want to keep in mind
that this fact that I've
been describing to you
is, to a first approximation,
only to a first approximation,
independent of social
security arrangements.
Franco, unless I miss my guess,
will want to talk to you a bit
about Social Security.
But the main function of
the social security system
is to determine how
much of the national pie
goes to the old
folks and how they
finance their access to their
share of the national pie.
But what there is to
divide in any decade,
in the decade from 2040
to 2050, for instance,
is what is produced
in that decade.
The social security rolls
don't directly effect that.
But they do indirectly.
They do because the
social security rules
influence retirement decisions.
They may provide incentives
to retire earlier or later.
Older retirement would
relieve the aging problem.
In fact, in recent years,
the age of retirement
has been decreasing,
not only in the US,
but elsewhere in the
industrial world as well.
And that reinforces the
effect of an aging population.
The real offset to having a
smaller working population
is higher productivity.
We know that output
per hour work
will be higher in
2050 than it is now.
An important question is
whether productivity growth
can be accelerated as
a matter of policy,
sort of as a conscious
decision of the society.
The answer to that
is probably yes,
although it is really impossible
to be quantitative about it.
And that brings me
to a question that I
think you would
like to talk about
and I don't like to
talk about, the question
that you read in the newspapers
or on the web or wherever.
Are we on the verge
of or are we already
into some sort of new
industrial revolution,
a new economy that will make the
kinds of mundane considerations
that I've been talking
about obsolete?
A simpler question is
whether the acceleration
of productivity that has
happened between 1995
and this year, and 2000,
whether that acceleration
is sustainable for
the next 50 years?
By the way, even the rate
of productivity growth
between 1995 and 2000
is not noticeably faster
than it was between
1950 and 1972.
In round numbers, output
per hour worked in the US
rose at a rate
between 1% and 1.5%
a year in the years
between 1972 and 1995.
And in the five years or four
years between 1995 and 1999,
it rose between
2% and 3% a year,
and even faster so far in 2000.
That's a big difference.
It seems like a
small difference.
Does productivity go up at 1% a
year or 2% a year or 2% a year
or 3% a year?
But over a 50 year period,
1% productivity growth
increases productivity by
65%, roughly 2% by 170%,
and 3% by 338%.
So what you will
be able to consume
per person on the
average in 2000
really depends in a big
way on a percent here
and a percent there
in the annual rate
of productivity increase.
Will the good fortune of
the last few years continue?
I don't know.
Extrapolating from four or
five years of observation
to 50 years is not a
comfortable activity.
It helps if you can
look a little deeper.
We can look a little deeper.
But the observational
basis is still very slim.
Mark Twain said in Life
on the Mississippi,
"Isn't science wonderful?
You get such a lot of conjecture
on such a small allowance
of fact."
And we don't-- we're lacking a
good empirical basis for trying
to extrapolate
productivity increase.
One serious investigation
I know shows that outside
of durable goods manufacturing,
outside of that part
of the economy that that
makes durable goods,
there has been practically
no technological,
no improvement in
pure productivity
during the past five years.
And interestingly
enough, about 80%
of the investment in
information technology
goes outside of durable
goods manufacturing.
Outside of that part
of manufacturing,
there's very small increment
of productivity growth.
And it is over accounted
for by the sheer capital
investment and improved
educational status
of the workforce.
So there's not much
left to be accounted
for by improved technology.
This suggests to
me that we will be
lucky to achieve the same
gains in the standard of living
in the next 50 years that
we did in the past 50 years.
We would need faster
productivity growth
than in the past 50 years to
offset the drag from aging.
I think there's a chance
that we'll get it.
But there is really
no certainty,
nothing remotely like certainty,
that we will get a lot more.
What this suggests
to me is that we
need to pursue technological
improvement, not
merely in information
technology, but in other fields
as well.
It might be a good idea
if somebody majored in
something other than the
EECS once in a while.
[CHEERING]
That still leaves
us with inequality
and the problem of the
unskilled and uneducated.
Even suppose that we can manage
the acceleration productivity
to offset the drag that comes
from an older population,
we would still have
that problem of dealing
with the unskilled
and uneducated.
The next 50 years
appear, if it is
a period of rapid
technological innovation,
could make that
problem worse unless we
find some way of tackling the
problems of the bottom third
of the income distribution.
It's not clear that we have
either ideas, new ideas
or any willingness to
do something about that.
And I will leave it there
and turn the floor over
to my colleague Modigliani.
[APPLAUSE]
MODIGLIANI: When I was
asked to join Paul and Bob
on this occasion, I immediately
thought or remembered
a famous line from my great poet
Dante Alighieri, the great poet
of Italy, who tells how
he got into the beginning
of the inferno and
there he was met--
he was lost-- and he
was met by Virgil.
And while they were
talking, in came Homer.
And then Dante says, and I
was third among such genius.
[LAUGHTER]
I hope I can keep it up.
Let's see.
First of all, let me say that I
had the privilege of suggesting
the title for tonight
because I thought, and I
wanted to be sure, everybody
would be interested.
Now, everybody here must
be either interested
or have lived the
last 50 years or must
expect to live in the next 50.
So everybody should be involved.
Next, let me say
that in general, I
have developed ideas that
are similar to those of Bob,
and I generally agree with
his analysis his conclusions.
So let me stress the few points
where I have something to add.
And I say they
are not that many.
One thing is that,
I want to point out,
we have seen that the last 50
years have been exceptional
in terms of growth, have seen
people get a lot better off,
a lot richer.
I want to point out
that, in effect, there
is a group of people
that did even better.
And that is our group.
We were particularly
fortunate because we
had in addition to this
growth and productivity,
we had three things
working for us.
First, a stock
market boom, we find
that our wealth
has been multiplied
without our doing anything.
I never expected that I
would have so much wealth
as I end up having.
It's completely beyond
my wildest thoughts.
Whatever I didn't put or we
didn't put in the stock market,
we put into real estate.
And that is just as much,
again, pure luck as not.
Now, there is a
slight difference
that they, on the
whole, the real estate
has a reason for rising
because land is fixed
and population is expanding
and income is expanding.
Therefore, the value of land,
particularly urban land,
must tend to rise.
There is a good reason.
In the case of the stock
market, there really
isn't any good reason.
And I think and I
have said many times
that much of what is going
on in the stock market
reflects a bubble, not
entirely, not entirely.
There is-- let me
put it this way.
The price of a share can be
seen as depending on the profit
it earns multiplied by
the profit earnings ratio,
how much--
and price earning ratio,
what is the price per dollar.
So dollar earned times
price earnings gives you
the price of the share.
Now, what has happened
in this period
is that both the earnings
have grown rapidly
and the price
earnings have gone up.
And the growth of the earnings
is partly a reflection
of this very sound economy.
It's a reflection of the
productivity, a reflection
of many things and rather
acquiescent labor behavior,
which is sort of
allowed on this level.
But the rise in the
price earning ratio,
which keeps going on,
is not of this kind.
That is the bubble.
There is no reason why as
long as the earnings grow
at a constant rate, there is no
reason why is the price earning
ratio should rise.
If it rises, it is
because of the bubble.
And what's a bubble?
It's a situation where a price,
a ridiculously high price
is justified by the
fact that everybody
expects that the next price
next year will be even higher.
So no matter how ridiculous it
is, as long as it keeps rising,
it's justified.
And this, by the way, one
learns from Paul's work
to some extent.
And the trouble is that as--
if the process continues and
the price continues to rise,
it justifies the
price, but the price
gets more and more ridiculous.
It gets more and more
out of line with reality.
And we economists always of
think of a famous example,
the so-called tulip
bulb boom or bubble
where tulips suddenly--
where the price of tulips
went up many, many
hundreds of times.
And there was no good reason.
Eventually the thing collapsed
because at some point,
people think the price
is ridiculously high.
And they do-- I'm not
willing to bid it any higher.
And then it stops growing.
When it stops growing, it
cannot hold, collapses.
So I think that bubble
has been-- made us rich
and may present
a problem for you
from now on into the future.
Because I think at
some point, there
is going to be a realignment.
The case to some extent
will be true in real estate.
And there the piece of luck
that we have had completely
destroyed is Medicare.
Medicare is being paid
by the young for the old.
But when we were
young, we didn't pay
because Medicare didn't exist.
[LAUGHTER]
So you are paying for
us on the expectation
that somebody will pay for you.
If we never paid anything and
we got that incredible boom
just as we were getting old
and in the need of Medicare.
So these three things are
very hard to reproduce.
Now, however, we
have done so well.
And some of this, as I
say, is not reproducible.
So I agree with Bob
that you are not
likely to do quite as well,
no matter what, quite as well
as some of us has done.
Now, of course, because of
we are unexpectedly rich,
we may be leaving you young
people larger inheritance
than we might have
done otherwise.
And that will help
you to some extent,
will carry over,
but not completely.
Now we have to have that
this great development
in this country still
is somewhat unique.
Because the other
major competitor,
the other part of
the world that has
similar capacities, similar
qualities of labor, capital, et
cetera is Europe.
And Europe is not
doing anywhere as well.
And why aren't
they doing as well?
Well, first of all,
objectively, Europe
still has something like
10%, 11% unemployment rate,
average unemployment rate.
It depends, it varies from
one country to another.
But their average is still 11%.
And furthermore, the
way they are moving,
they're not likely to
cut that down quickly.
They are very happy
when they grow 3%.
And 3% is not much to cut
into the unemployment,
just enough to absorb the
productivity and population
growth.
Now, why are they
doing so badly?
Well, I think the answer is--
Paul gave it before--
because they do not read Keynes.
They refuse to
understand Keynes.
They are stupid enough
so that they will not
read and understand
that if there is not
enough money in the economy,
you have unemployment.
OK, so they keep a
policy which is wrong.
And they keep it continuously
even to the present time.
You just had an example.
With 10% unemployment,
the central bank
raises interest rates
without understanding
that the way to cut unemployment
is the American way--
invest, invest, invest.
That's why we are doing so well.
That's why they are
doing so poorly.
That's, by the way,
exactly what Keynes said.
Investment is what
determines income, OK?
That's the major determiner.
Now, it can be bailed out
by government or private
here in this
country, fortunately,
it's mostly private investment.
That's what I think.
But that is what is
driving us so high.
And that's in the way of Europe.
I do hope that at some point,
they will learn Keynes.
There still is hope.
I have been fighting my way.
But I have just--
a couple of months ago, I
wrote a paper explaining this.
And one of my colleagues said,
poor Modigliani, he still
believes in Keynes.
That's the European mentality.
To which I replied, poor guy,
you never understood Keynes.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, as we look ahead
into the future,
aside from these
known advantages,
there are some definite
problems to worry about.
And I would like
to mention some.
First of all, there is the
fact of the Wall Street bubble,
that when the bubble
explodes, as I expect,
there will be unpleasant
consequences in the economy.
There will be very likely
some decrease in demand
because consumption
will decrease.
You keep reading everywhere
about the wealth effect.
Consumption is so high
because of the wealth effect.
You seldom see it,
footnote it says, that is
to be found for the first time
in Modigliani's life-cycle.
That's where the
wealth effect was first
mentioned in the 1950s.
Now it's become very popular.
But that effect
certainly, I'm sure,
I believe that that is
an important thing that
has supported our boom, although
more than supporting our boom,
it has done something
that's not so good,
creating a large deficit
in the balance of payment.
Remember that that is a problem.
We have a gigantic debt.
We have a gigantic deficit.
That is, we spent
more than we earned.
We used more resources
than we produced, OK?
Now, one has to be
careful in distinguishing
whether having a
deficit or being in debt
is bad, per se, from the size.
The fact of being in debt is
not, per se, bad or in deficit.
Think of anybody like
you in your age group.
You are maybe who will
be buying a house.
In the year in which you buy
a house, your income is $1,000
and you spend $20,000.
So you have your terrific
deficit and you go into debt.
Is that bad?
No.
Because against the
debt, you have an asset.
The same thing is
true in this country.
We borrow.
But we borrow to invest.
So essentially,
against the debt,
we do have earning assets.
And there is nothing per
se wrong with borrowing.
The problem is that
if you go too far then
the creditors may begin
to get worried, OK?
Yeah, you're investing, but
look at how big your debt is.
If something goes wrong,
you will be unable to pay.
And that's the danger we face
in our balance of payment,
that it is conceivable
that at some point
foreigners will refuse
to continue to lend us
or to buy the shares
of our companies,
to provide the capital,
because they've had enough.
And if that happens and if they
want to stop bringing in money
and the dollar might
begin to stop appreciating
and might begin to depreciate,
then they may be wrong.
Everybody may want to
get out of the dollar
before it depreciates further.
And then the United States
is no different from Malaysia
or from Singapore--
no, Singapore
did all right, but any of
the states of the governments
that appear to be in
complete disarray.
Because with further changes,
if people want to get out,
there is nothing
you can do except
let the currency devalue.
That's the only-- you
have to let it go.
When that happens,
you have inflation.
When you have inflation,
the central bank
will raise interest
rates like [INAUDIBLE]..
Investment will decline.
And we could have
serious consequences,
including contributing to
the stock market crash.
Because as people get out,
they want to sell the shares
they own and have
additional pressure.
So that complex of very high--
I mean very high-- stock
prices bubble, the deficit
and the balance of
payment is a complex that
could generate some serious
problems in the future.
It need not.
That is, it is
possible that things
would sort of quiet down.
But the main way in which
we could help the situation
would be by saving more.
Because if we save more, we
can serve those investment,
we can finance those
investments without the need
to borrow abroad.
So that would be a
very desirable thing.
Now, let me come to another
problem which I think
is a part of the long-run view.
And that is what
Bob has mentioned,
the problem of Social Security.
We do know that we have a
system of Social Security which
is called pay as you go, a
system in which the pensions
are not paid out
of the accumulation
that you have made.
See, in the normal system,
or in my life cycle,
people accumulate wealth.
And they use that
wealth to live when
they are old, OK, to
essentially pay their pension.
The present system is instead,
you do not build up a wealth.
You take the money that
is contributed by people.
And instead of putting it aside,
you use it to pay pensions.
So there is no accumulation.
Now, that has
several consequences.
One consequence is that
the system is unstable
because the relation between
contribution and pensions
depends on how fast
the economy grows.
If the economy
goes fast, then you
can get out more than you put
in because there are more people
to pay with their
contribution then
there were when you started.
So you could get more money
than you could put in.
But if you are promised
a certain return,
that's like an
implicit interest rate,
if you promise a certain return.
And if the growth changes,
then you cannot deliver
the promises.
And what's happened in this
country and throughout most
of the world is that as
population growth declines,
you cannot fulfill those
promises because the ratio
of people that pay contribution
to those who get pensions
changes and deteriorates.
You have less and less
people paying per person
taking a pension.
That is sure to create problems.
Now, how much and how bad will
depend on what we do about it.
The present administration
has no program to handle that.
That is, it will put in, throw
in the surplus of the budget
to support Social Security.
But that will not get you beyond
the middle of the next century.
By that time,
approximately, there
will have to be something like
a 50% increase in the dues
in the what you have to pay
in the payroll tax or a cut
in benefits.
And here is the point where
I have something to offer.
I've been working now
for a couple of years
on finding a solution
to this problem
and find that the
solution exists
and it's really rather simple.
The solution
consists in creating
a so-called funded system.
A funded system is one in which
the contributions, instead
of being used to pay pensions,
are used to accumulate wealth.
And then when you retire,
that wealth and not
the young people, but that
wealth pays your pension.
Now, once you have been
able, you've made the change,
you can see that this
system is far better.
Because in the first
place, it is cheaper.
We have figured out that under
the pay as you go, by 2050
or thereafter, you will
have to pay about 20%,
21% contribution instead
of the 12% of today.
With our system, you
would pay only about 7%.
So it would be able to
cut, get over the crisis,
and cut contributions
very substantially,
by about a third.
And furthermore, a funded system
is less sensitive to variations
in growth.
It's completely, well, largely
unaffected by population growth
because population affects
the picture because they
are young support the old.
When the old are supported
by their capital,
they don't care how many
young people there are.
Now, you have to
understand the moment,
how that fits into the
picture that Bob has given
and which is very
commonly accepted.
The idea is that, how can you
avoid getting poorer or paying
less pensions if you
have less people, more
old people to supply?
Because, he says,
that's the pie.
If you've got more for them,
you've got less for the others.
Well, the answer is
that under our system,
the pie is not fixed.
The pie precisely
depends on what you need.
If you have many old people,
you will have large accumulation
from the past, which
will take care of it.
They may be to the point where
the accumulation, the fund,
will be decreasing because
they'll pay out than it gets.
But that's all right.
Paying out more
than it gets simply
means that you would be
liquidating some assets.
Society as a whole,
which is not growing,
would need less assets anyway.
So the thing would largely
take care of itself.
So this is, I think, a kind of
possibility that gives us hope.
I mean, obviously, I don't
have time to go into details.
But I should have brought
with me the website
where you can find this.
By the way, I can tell you,
if you look in the website
under MIT and under
Franco Modigliani,
you will find
there that there is
the latest version of my plan.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SOLOW: Thanks.
There are a couple of
microphones set up,
at least in that aisle
and in that aisle.
I can't see if there--
I think those are
all that there is.
But we're happy to have some
conversation with anyone who
has a question or a
pronouncement or a theorem.
Who knows?
AUDIENCE: You'd have to be
very brave for a pronouncement
in this group.
A question to all
of the panel has
to do with aging and also
your solution, Dr. Modigliani.
It seems as if you're making an
assumption that the aging will
have an effect which is bad.
You were mentioning that
retirement age is going down
rather than up.
You know, but look
at the three of you.
In many parts of the
United States at least,
people may have retired, but
they may also still be working.
The fact of people
being, of older people
being healthier and healthier,
I wonder it's a really--
and I just don't
know if, you know,
I'm just asking
because I don't know.
Has there been any
work done to really try
to quantify that aging effect?
And then I'll look
at your website
for the second question.
SOLOW: Well, let me--
I think there is a
little illusion here
that is shared always
by people like us.
By us I mean everyone
here in this room.
We're people who on the whole--
well, let me back
up a minute and say,
one obvious way for
a society to deal
with this aging
fact, demography,
is to prolong the working life.
Just as was just said,
we are living longer.
We're living-- we're
having healthier old age.
Why should not the
working life be prolonged?
People like us who like our
work, who rather don't like
the notion of retiring, we
want to hang on to the office
and continue to work, that seems
a little more obvious than it
is.
The society is full of
people who do dull work
and don't like it.
And they will not
be happy to be told
that, well, the way
we deal with this
is for you instead of retiring
at 65 or more likely 62 or 61
as you had planned, you will, of
course, use your healthy years
being a clerk in a department
store for another five or 10
years or for doing one or
another kind of work that's
not so pleasant and
not so rewarding.
I think it's
inevitable, actually,
that the working life
will be prolonged
in the US and elsewhere
simply because people
live longer and are healthier.
And the way to deal
with the productivity
problem that emerges is to
prolong the age of retirement.
I think the scheme that
Franco was describing,
the connection between
what he was saying
and what I was saying is
that this extra accumulation
of capital that comes
with the funded system
is precisely what gives you
the extra productivity that's
needed to support--
SAMUELSON: Exactly.
SOLOW: --a population, a smaller
fraction of which is working.
The amount of work performed
by the population measured
in hours will diminish.
The decreasing age of
retirement is not an illusion.
For people like us, it is.
But for people who work
in automobile factories
and now live in RVs,
recreational vehicles
in Florida, it is not the case.
So something like the
extra capital accumulation
is what we need.
Franco, did you want to
add something to that.
MODIGLIANI: Well, I'll
just add one thing.
First of all that every
thinking person agrees
that the least you
want to do is you
want to give incentives
to work longer.
Whether or not you
make it mandatory,
you want to give incentives.
And that's not an obvious thing.
I mean, let me remind you
of the example of the folly
of my former
country, Italy, where
the reasoning was once you
retire, you have a pension.
SOLOW: Do you want to take
a turn on this question?
SAMUELSON: No.
MODIGLIANI: You shouldn't work
anymore because otherwise you
get richer.
Therefore, if you work,
we'll tax it heavily.
That's completely
the wrong reasoning.
If you work, the fact
that you get richer, fine,
that's your incentive
to work longer.
So that's exactly we should
provide that kind of a thing.
We might also have
some shift in the age,
in the standard age
when you retire in order
to maintain the
relation between-- see,
this is particularly
important with respect
to life expectancy.
Because aside from the getting
older because of the smaller
number of births, you
also have the fact
that longevity is increasing.
And longevity
increasing requires
additional contributions
in some form.
And one way to cut that
is by lengthening by time
the retirement age
to life expectancy.
SOLOW: Why don't we try
the other microphone?
AUDIENCE: Professors, in his
remarks, Professor Solow talked
about the success of
American economics
and the sustainability of
rapid growth and productivity.
This is, to me, a
global question.
The model that was taught
to the word by Ford
in the beginning of the century,
and by the American society
in its whole, is a
model that is sustained
by a very high level of
consumption of goods,
personal transportation,
that is cars versus bus,
and the production of
short-lasting products instead
of quality products and what.
America is the first
country in the world
has number of cars per
capita that is a success.
But even the most
polluting country
in the world in terms
of the amount of energy
that's used per capita.
My question is now,
what will happen
in the next decade,
the next 50 years when
energetic resources will
be more crucial and costly
and when some rapidly growing
countries China, for instance,
will ask for the same
level of welfare of US?
What will happen to global
economics at that point?
And the second question that--
[LAUGHTER]
--what can be done--
sorry-- what can be done to
develop a sustainable economic
model in the next five years?
SOLOW: Paul, you
want to tackle that?
MODIGLIANI: I didn't
understand a word.
SAMUELSON: Well, one
person, one question.
It's obviously the
case that the US,
with its early high
standard of living,
has been plundering the
exhaustive and exhausting
resources at a much faster rate.
And if we are successful
in other parts
of the world in raising levels
of standard of living to the US
level, that will mean a
billion Chinese are plundering
at the American rate,
a billion Indians
will be plundering at that rate.
Scientists will always
be finding new resources.
And in the age after
nuclear, probably scientists
can do a lot of
winning of the battle.
But there still is the
second law of thermodynamics.
And there still is
some limitation.
And so it will
become very important
not to have SUVs
versus efficient cars
just because people want them.
And this is one of those
places where you can't
leave it to laissez-faire.
Because if it's left
to laissez-faire
and I want an SUV,
I'll have an SUV.
But my freedom ends where your
nose begins as I swing my cane.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
--we're all breathing
the same molecules.
Julius Caesar died.
And I'm breathing
some of his molecules.
So we really are interdependent.
And I think there will
have to be, in 2050, when,
instead of our having 23%
of world output with only 5%
of the population, we
will have something
like 9% of world
output and there will
be a lot more demands on it.
And so this doesn't mean that
we can't use a pricing system.
We actually are using a pricing
system to ration out pollution.
But we can't rely only
on the pricing system.
We need the common
rule of the road.
AUDIENCE: Professor
Samuelson, in particular,
but any of you who
would care to answer,
I didn't hear any of you
speak of the interaction
between, on the one hand,
globalization, which I think
does bring, what you
were speaking of,
Professor Samuelson, the
bigness being the enemy
in some sense, and the
interplay between that
and democratic
institutions, which
are very much more
on a different scale
and no longer related
in any direct way.
SAMUELSON: I thought meeting
with students someone
might bring up the
question that was bothering
the mob in Seattle who were
protesting against the World
Trade Organization because the
low prices at which I can buy
at Wal-Mart are as low as they
are because somebody in China
is making a very low wage.
And this takes me back
to an election in 1962
in Massachusetts.
There was Professor
Stuart Hughes
who was a very liberal professor
of history ran for Senate.
And he ran against Teddy
Kennedy, the reactionary,
right?
And he was in favor,
Hughes, a friend of mine,
but not a student
of mine, he was
in favor of a $7 minimum
wage at that time.
At that time, it was about $2.
He multiplied it by a couple.
And I said to him, you know,
the traffic won't bear this.
We won't be competitive
with other countries.
He said, you don't
understand, Samuelson.
I'm for a $7 minimum wage
every place in the world.
[LAUGHTER]
And I said to him, that is the
cruelest remark I have heard
in all of my long lifetime.
Because a $7 1962
real minimum wage
US purchasing power
would have caused,
of the five billion people
then alive, about 4 billion
to die of unemployment
and starvation.
So the requisite problem--
this is what makes
economists such awful people,
you're even awful to
your own children.
You say these practical things.
What you have to ask is not do
I want a poor little girl 12
years old in China to
be getting the wage
that Walmart eventually
pays and, of course,
the answer is almost nobody but
a few sadists would want that.
But what are the alternatives
if you don't have globalization.
How has Africa fared being
outside of the globalization
system?
What converted
Hobbes' jungle, where
life was short,
nasty, and brutish,
into the present world?
It was Newton.
It was the age after Newton.
And there is no way that
the consumers of Walmart,
given their quantum
of altruism, are
going to give up their
comfortable standard of living
in order to have a
unilateral transfer, a gift,
to those workers.
And so you have to ask
yourself, in the next 10 years,
will the emerging
market countries
have an upward trend in
real wages for their people,
earned by their people in
the exchange system or not?
And a simple-minded
support of globalization
under all conditions is wrong.
But a simple-minded
rejection of it--
now, I said I was going
to be nonpartisan.
But I do have to say, I don't
agree with candidate Buchanan.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have a question
for Professor Modigliani.
You talk about changing
the pension system
from the current
system to a system
where you fund, basically,
your pensions through time,
you start investing them now.
One of the places where you
would invest those pensions
would be the stock market.
And earlier in your
remarks, you talked
about sort of the irrationality
that's inherent in the stock
market currently.
MODIGLIANI: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering
if you could elaborate
a little bit on and
how you would insulate,
how you would insulate the
funds for those pensions
from the stock market volatility
and how you would make sure
that people actually
do get their money
at the end of their lives.
MODIGLIANI: Let me answer
briefly because that's
the time we have.
First of all, let's be
clear that in my system,
all the money that's
contributed goes
not into your own portfolio, it
goes into a common portfolio.
The idea, to be
nonpartisan, of Bush
that it should go into
your own portfolio
is completely wrong because
it makes Social Security
into a gambling casino,
OK, exactly what it does.
[APPLAUSE]
You are forced to save.
You should know what comes out.
And that requires
defined benefits.
Now, how do I invest the
money that's accumulated?
Essential in a portfolio
that mimics the economy
composed of the same
way as the market.
Now that doesn't prevent the
market from some movements.
And right now, it's too high.
The specific problem
that it is now too high
I handle the following way.
Before my reform is
accepted, there'll
be plenty of time for
the bubble to deflate.
Then, when it's
deflated, we will invest.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'd like to come back
to the globalization topic.
The reason, at least
from my point of view,
is that many of the products
you can buy in Wal-Mart
are so cheap is because
low wages are very
low in developing countries,
but a reason for that
is that, in large part, because
of repressive governments,
such as in Indonesia or in
Latin America, for example.
And the US and Europe,
to some extent,
supports these
governments, actually
nurtures these governments.
Because usually corporations
get a higher yield out
of a dictatorship.
So in a sense, there is
some unfairness there.
Because these repressive
governments actually,
well, they attack unions and
they attack labor movements.
And so this is actually a
very unfair form, reason
why these wages are so low.
Because the labor, power
of labor in these countries
is very weak
because of violence.
And I'd like to know, hear what
you have to say about that.
SOLOW: Well, let me
take a shot at that.
I want to separate two things.
The fundamental reason why wages
are low in developing countries
is because productivity
is low in those countries.
That's far more-- if
you were to-- if you
were to classify poor
countries or all the countries
of the world in terms of
the degree of democracy
that's available,
the correlation
between that and earning
power is very small.
The fundamental
reason for the poverty
of underdeveloped,
undeveloped countries
is their low productivity.
Bad governance,
dictatorships, tyrannies
of one kind or another
surely make things worse.
But if we're going to be--
deal rationally with
the world economy,
we have to distinguish
between the globalization
in the sense of open trade
where possible, migration
possibilities, free
movement of capital
from places where there's
a lot of it to places
where there's a little of it.
That has to be distinguished
from dictatorship, tyranny,
lack of democracy.
From my own point
of view, I think
that over the past 50 years,
American foreign policy
has been much too tolerant of
dictatorships and repressive
governments in the third world.
And I have certainly--
and I imagine all of us here
have opposed that politically.
But the step from
that to saying one
ought to restrict trade with
poor countries is a bad step.
It's an illogical step.
Generally it's the
representatives
of workers in poor countries who
want open trade, not oppose it.
So I think we should try to
keep the political side of this
from the economic side of
it separate intellectually.
Because otherwise, it's not
possible to think rationally
about those things.
SAMUELSON: I would not
minimize the harmful effects
upon future standards of living
of repressive government.
It'd be very difficult
in a Nigeria,
even though it had oil, in
the Congo, rich with metals,
to develop at all.
And when colonial powers
moved out, at the beginning,
they were not
repressive governments.
But without the
repressive governments,
they didn't spring instantly
into high wage countries.
If you just begin the process
and the international division
of labor can help when there
isn't a repressive government
and it won't help much where
there is such repressive
government that nobody feels
secure in doing any saving,
nobody gets the result
of their productivity,
there is no way of
sending students
to get advanced
training, so there always
are an eclectic number of
explanations to each problem.
That's why economics is boring.
But to me, that's
why it's interesting.
AUDIENCE: Professor Solow,
this is mostly for you.
With the new productivity
numbers between 2% and 3%
annually, what do you see as
the correct Fed's position
on interest rates, which
is currently at 6.50%?
But historically speaking,
that's over-inflated.
What is your opinion?
SOLOW: About interest
rates here in the US or--
AUDIENCE: Yes, interest
rates here in the US.
SOLOW: Well, the Federal
Reserve, the central bank
in the US has, I think, in
formulating and executing
monetary policy has been
well-aware and reflective
about the growth
of productivity.
They may occasionally have
been overoptimistic, in fact.
But on the whole,
I think that as--
are you ready for a
complicated answer here?
AUDIENCE: It's my job.
I can take a complicated answer.
SOLOW: There is a
real danger that--
a real possibility,
I think, that we
are managing this period of
rapid expansion with little
or no inflation as a result
of an unexpected acceleration
of productivity, which has not
been fully reflected in wages
and therefore in--
and therefore prices
are able to move along
at a relatively low level.
I think the Fed has performed
extraordinarily well in seeing
that this lucky
period-- if it's luck--
is translated into high
employment and increasing
production.
They are nervous, as we're
all nervous, that the timing,
when this particular
lucky period ends,
the timing is going to be
very difficult to get right.
So hold your breath.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MODIGLIANI: Can I just
add a word to this?
I think the Federal
Reserve on the whole
has done a really excellent job.
They may have been
lucky to some extent,
but they have shown
the right mixture
of courage and restraint.
I think they're
really quite good.
And I think-- when I
said before that Europe
has a lot of unemployment and
they don't understand Keynes,
one of the manifestation of this
is that the European Central
Bank has only one
instruction, avoid inflation,
whereas the American
Constitution says,
see to it that output
is large as possible
subject to the
condition that there
should be minimum inflation.
And that makes a
good difference.
And I think we see that
policy being pursued here.
And you see the policy
of saying no inflation
leads to very tight
and high unemployment.
Because then you're sure.
If you've got 20%
unemployed, then you
don't have to worry
about inflation.
SOLOW: I'm afraid we're
going to have to--
to stop now.
And although my understanding
is there's going to be some food
and drink outside
after we're done.
And I at least, and I
imagine my colleagues,
are happy to stand around
and chat some more.
But the introductions are going
to go in flow up hill here.
I would like to introduce
to you Marty Zimmerman, who
is the Vice President
for Government
Relations of the
Ford Motor Company,
is a PhD in economics
from this institution,
and is, in large part,
responsible for the program
of which this
evening is the start.
Marty.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ZIMMERMAN: Thank you, Bob.
I was hoping you
wouldn't introduce me
and then I could use my line a
la Admiral Stockdale, who am I
and what am I doing here?
But having introduced
me, I just want
to express my
thanks to the panel,
to professors Samuelson, Solow,
and Modigliani for a really
interesting evening.
I'm thrilled, personally,
to be part of this.
As Professor Solow has said, I
was a student mid-century here,
mid-century in terms
of the between the '50
and the 2000 period.
And I derived
tremendous benefits
from studying from
these gentlemen.
I think we all got a taste
tonight of what an enriching
experience that was.
And I don't mean solely
in Franco's terms
that we all found ourselves
wealthier in the year 2000.
Although as the developer of
the life-cycle hypothesis,
do you feel that you
consume too little?
MODIGLIANI: That's right.
ZIMMERMAN: Anyway,
Ford Motor Company--
MODIGLIANI: I'm going to
go consume more outside.
[LAUGHTER]
ZIMMERMAN: But
Ford Motor Company
is really delighted
to be able to sponsor
this series of Nobel laureates.
I think this was a
terrific kick-off.
I hope, but doubt, that
we'll be able to sustain
this level of quality as
we go through this series.
This is one part, and
really a small part,
of a very deep and evolving
relationship between Ford Motor
Company--
by the way when I
come to Cambridge,
it always helps recognition if
I mention that Ford owns Volvo.
So that's-- but it is really
only one part of a, as I said,
a deep and evolving
relationship involving research
and teaching, which
I am excited about.
We are-- I know at Ford
we're very excited about it.
And I believe our
counterparts here at MIT
are excited because we've
done some great things.
And we look forward to
doing even greater things
in the future.
My second role
tonight is to tell you
that there is a
reception outside.
Since we've had such
a tremendous turnout--
and, in fact, I was told
there were overflow crowds
in several parts of campus--
we've moved the
reception outside.
I trust the weather
is cooperating.
So, again, thank
you all for coming.
And, again, thank
you to the panelists
for a truly great evening.
[APPLAUSE]